in 2020 researchers showed off how
animal a four-legged robot could amble
across a variety of settings without
falling but this version of animal
wasn't able to anticipate what its next
steps would reveal the robot was relying
solely on proprioceptive perception
awareness of its internal state such as
leg positioning or speed
since the robot had to feel out its
environment it moved slowly through
space to increase animal speed
researchers at eth zurich added
exteroceptive perception onto the bot
the ability for animal to see upcoming
terrain
the researchers installed depth sensors
that animal use to plan its future steps
while maintaining speed and stability
but these maps aren't perfect the depth
sensors interpret soft unstable surfaces
such as snow as solid surfaces that
can't be walked on
as a fix the researchers trained animal
to revise its map when proprioceptive
perception conflicted with exteroceptive
perception
before seeing this strategy in action
they had to train the robot's controller
the computer system in charge of the
robot's movements how to navigate in a
variety of settings
the researchers created a virtual
environment where the controller could
experience different terrains faster
than the real world
one controller had access to a lot of
information about its surroundings from
terrain to friction so that it could
develop optimal movements
in real life animal would not have
access to so much data
so they taught a student controller to
mimic these ideal behaviors using only a
height map
they added noise to the height mapping
tests to simulate scenarios where the
depth sensors might fail
then it was time to test animal in the
lab
they set a foam block in front of animal
which appeared as a solid surface on its
terrain map
once animals stepped on the obstacle the
robot altered its terrain map downward
stepping on top of the block with its
hind legs
to test the robot's skills in the real
world the researchers had animal take a
hike through etzel mountain in
switzerland
the robot smoothly traversed a path
riddled with roots and vegetation
completing the hike about as quickly as
a human could
in most experiments the researchers
could see animal as they controlled it
with a joystick they successfully
deployed the robot
semi-autonomously during the darpa
subterranean challenge
instead of actively controlling its
direction a human sent animal a command
to move to its next position and the
robot would plan its own path there
in one hour four animal robots alongside
several flying bots successfully
explored an underground circuit of
tunnels and caves they won the
competition by detecting 23 hidden
artifacts along their path
it's a promising start to how
researchers envision animals destiny
leading search and rescue missions or
exploring planets
in the future researchers hope to deploy
animal fully autonomously don't be
alarmed if you see animal being tested
in an environment near you
[Music]